and now we meet a real Hollywood paradox
this actress died in her last picture
and they gave her an Oscar on that basis
I should be three ahead of Walt Disney
ladies and gentlemen miss Susan Hayward
it's my honor to present the Academy
Award to the artist voted by his fellows
in the industry as having given the best
performance by an actor the nominees are
Laurence Harvey room at the top Charlton
Heston Ben Hur Jack Lemmon some like it
hot Paul Muni the last angry man and
James Stewart anatomy of a murder
Charlton Heston Ben
it's really true when you stand here you
want to thank everybody who ever knew in
this business I feel like starting with
the first secretary or whoever let me
sneak into a Broadway casting call ten
years ago this month I made my first
picture in Hollywood and since that time
I've worked with a great many of you and
every one of you did something to put me
here tonight as for Ben Hur and who
worked on that most of you you've been
applauding most of them have been
applauded earlier this evening including
Willie but I would like especially to
thank not only all of you and all of
them but Willie and Christopher Frye and
Sam Zimbalist who gave more than any of
us thank you